bonjour bienvenue au jardin arboré thème
d'ilex donc c'est un jardin à la fois
jardin et arboretum où on y trouve de
belles collections de plantes et
notamment une collection d'ilex alors
ici il ya beaucoup d'eau en fait c'est
la particularité du site
ce sont des petits canaux qui viennent
de la rivière les mauves en fait c'est
un ancien marais qui étaient asséchées
au 6e siècle par le moins de saint
lyphard il ya quatre collections
nationales de plantes qui sont reconnus
dont principalement la plus importante
c'est celle d'ilex donc il ya 500
variétés de ou différentes mais on a
aussi une collection dos tu as dit à peu
près près de 200 variétés une collection
la stib qui fleurit bien en juin des
petites fleurs toutes légères au bord de
l'eau donc ça il ya 180 variété est
aussi une grosse collection c'est la
collection clématites des pépinières
travers à orléans et cette collection
clématites comprend à peu près 300
variétés
il ya toujours des fleurs depuis le
printemps il ya aussi des rosiers les
clématites qui fleurissent au printemps
il ya celle des t bonds les à steam
c'est plutôt au mois de juin
je mets juillet donc là c'est avec le
moment de venir les voir
et ensuite
vous avez ballet où on peut les voir
tout le temps à l'automne il ya les becs
de ou qui sont décoratives et après nous
rouvrons toujours fin octobre début
novembre pour les couleurs de tonnes ce
qu'on retrouve beaucoup d'érable dans le
site
une cinquantaine de variétés d'érable et
tous ses érables se colore en même temps
20 octobre
alors ici c'est vrai que les gens ont
parfois du mal à venir
il pense qu'il ya que des arbres mais ce
qui est faux parce que beaucoup de
beaucoup d'autres plantes et ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est l'atmosphère qui
est complètement différente on se trouve
mis en oeuvre avec au bord de l'eau
alors ce lieu a été créée planté par
pierre parisse il ya une trentaine
d'années qui a qui a planté en fait tout
s'est toutes ses collections de plantes
et il ya cinq ans il voulait arrêter et
ne trouvant pas de repreneur grand c'est
décidé on va le reprendre
on souhaitait pas que tout c'est toutes
ces collections de plantes soient
abandonnées on ouvre maintenant plus
facilement comme c'est ouvert tous les
après midis pendant la saison sauf le
mardi
ce qui fait que c'est facile d'accepter